merci c'est super sympa parce que là je
n'en pouvais plus de la ville
j'ai besoin de déconnecter ya pas de
social en plus à la saison d'avancé
c'est super mal passé je me suis
embrouillé avec les autres français tous
brouillé du coup un niveau loyers comme
ils sont tous partis tu vois c'est super
compliqué non mais vraiment c'est
vraiment cool de ta part t'inquiète tu
mèneras au jardin plus ses mots en plus
je viens de la campagne donc ce silence
a tellement que faire du bien
qu'est-ce que mais qu'est ce qu'il fait
là lui quoi ouais mon louer la maison
d'en face mais super c les colas
[Musique]
quel est le point commun entre la lozère
le cantal et la nièvre vous l'aurez
deviné ils sont situés dans la diagonale
du vide perdant chaque année des
habitants alors que la france en gagne
pourtant les jeunes sans barre dès
qu'ils peuvent ce qui fait qu'on y
trouve proportionnellement plus de vieux
qu'ailleurs et ces jeunes il se barre en
ville
en france ils sont désormais
majoritaires à y vivre et comme c'est la
période de la vie où l'on se marie on
s'attendrait naturellement ce que les
mairies urbaine soit prise d'assaut et
accuse le coup face à tous les néo
citadins désireux d'officialiser leur
relation
surtout qu'en principe le mariage est
célébré dans une commune où l'un des
deux époux doit justifier une résidence
continue d'au moins un mois
mais il n'en est rien c'est l'autre
point commun entre la lozère le cantal
et la nièvre ce sont des territoires
prisée pour les mariages
si tous les jeunes se barre en région
parisienne pour chercher du boulot les
franciliens quant à eux se barre à la
campagne pour se marient et pour se
confiner aussi mais ça c'est autre chose
vous l'aurez compris dans cet épisode on
va parler d'exode rural de reproduction
humaine de retour à la terre aussi et de
fractures territoriales évidemment et
pour commencer peut-être que l'on peut
se rafraîchir nos cours d'histoire de
collège
c'est quoi l'exode rural comme son nom
l'indiqué assez brutalement ce le fait
de se barrer des campagnes pour
rejoindre les villes c'est une dynamique
très ancienne que l'on constatait déjà
en egypte antique en europe une
dynamique d'exode rural a débuté dès le
moyen-âge à l'urbanisation
on trouve en ville les places publiques
avec des boutiques on y construit les
cathédrales et les universités on y
développe des services de nouveaux
secteurs économiques et un milieu
culturel qui rend l'endroit très
attrayant évidemment les capitales sont
les plus prisés par ailleurs la
centralisation en un seul point de
l'activité économique devient un enjeu
important en france avec la révolution
industrielle qui nécessitent de gros
infrastructures une importante main
d'oeuvre
et dont la production doit être proche
des voies de transport offre les il ne
cesse alors de séduire les salaires y
sont meilleures on y est plus ouvert on
y trouve deux meilleures écoles et
parfois même les seuls dans leur genre
on y associe aussi l'idée que l'on y est
moins impactés par le déterminisme
social et que l'on peut partir de zéro
pour gravir l'échelle sociale
puis les jeunes n'ont d'autre choix que
de monter en ville pour des emplois
journaliers ou saisonniers quand la
saison est creuse aussi c'est un peu la
version locale du rêve américain
par ailleurs en ces temps dans les
villes grignote les terres rurales ce
qui impacte fortement ceux qui vivent et
les forces soit à partir soit à se
convertir à ce nouveau mode de vie mais
ça on en reparlera après vêtu voilà ça
débarque de l'adil l'air de rien mais si
tu l'espère m apprête à un biocoop à la
place du bistrot au village il n'y a pas
de bistrot au village et babol est ce
que je te disais tu veux pas arrêter de
râler mais d'arroser là parce que c'est
ça mon mode de vie en fait et je t'avoue
que si tu t'y plier un peu ça
m'arrangerait bien quand même
en france l'exode rural débute vraiment
dans la seconde partie du 19e siècle il
n'est absolument pas uniforme des
territoires sont plus touchés que
d'autres
c'est surtout les régions montagneuses
et le sud de la france qui sont impactés
en effet l'intérêt est plus difficile à
exploiter ces travailleurs sont donc
plus fortement affectée par les
fluctuations des rendements agricoles et
de leur valeur économique d'un côté
l'augmentation de la productivité
diminue les besoins de main d'oeuvre
tout en augmentant la taille des
exploitations de l'autre les crises
agricoles viennent sonner le glas dans
beaucoup de régions la crise de 1890 au
phylloxéra par exemple un insecte
s'attaquant aux vignes mais de nombreux
ouvriers agricoles les petits paysans
hors-jeu et ceux là n'ont d'autre choix
que de partir par la fait boule de neige
des parents provoque d'autres
l'artisanat local voit sa clientèle
réduire les nombreux sont les artisans
qui alors emprunte le même chemin
comme cet exode touchent avant tout une
population en âge de se reproduire une
baisse de la natalité bien enfoncer un
peu plus le coût en france la part de la
population vivent en ville devient donc
majoritaires en 1931
cela ne fait donc pas si longtemps que
ça la bretagne nous sommes reclus pour
tourner cette vidéo a fait les frais de
cet exode
les crises agricoles ne l'ont pas
épargnée elle s'y ajouter l'effondrement
des manufactures textiles à base de lin
ou de chambres qui ont souffert de la
concurrence du coton et puis avec la
mécanisation de la marine marquant la
fin des bateaux à voile la demande s'est
effondrée avec la ligne de chemin de fer
brest-paris inauguré en 1965 beaucoup de
bretons partent et atterrissent à
montparnasse dans le 14e arrondissement
de paris qui devient le quartier breton
tertre à catholique certains décident
aussi de kits
la bretagne pour fuir le poids de la
religion les hommes deviennent ouvriers
les femmes deviennent boniche si bien
que cela inspire le personnage de
bécassine la bonne bretonne vu par la
bourgeoisie parisienne pour les immigrés
issus de la province comme on dit si
bien à paris ce n'est pas toujours
facile à vivre
quel bruit auquel on est peu habitué la
densité de population et surtout la
méfiance et le mépris qui sont souvent
de rigueur
les bretons se retrouve avec les kabyles
et les auvergnats qui subissent le même
sort pour s'entraider et savoyards dont
la région est annexée par la france en
1860 mais qui auparavant déjà se vider
au profit de la région parisienne et de
la région lyonnaise sont
particulièrement ciblés par la
xénophobie
à paris on les traite étrangers on les
accuse de voler le travail de locaux et
comme ils ne parlent pas toujours
français de parigny le français tout
court d'ailleurs lag l'autophobie et
souvent rendez vous à l'époque on
emploie le mot ça moyen pour désigner un
homme sale grossier ou brutale russe
très peu commode
le sous préfet de saint julien en
genevois haute savoie dans son rapport
du 8 juin 1874 ira même jusqu'à écrire
qu'il existe une conspiration permanente
et que les savoyards se soutiennent tous
entendu premier au dernier et qu'il faut
alors les assimiler pour éviter que le
contraire ne se passe j'imagine
évidemment évidemment aujourd'hui la
plupart des français ignorent alors que
cette savoie aujourd'hui bien nano ou là
où on descend depuis l'autoroute a6 pour
aller faire du ski et d'un elle était
considérée comme une région rustre et
étrangères dont les habitants arriérés
venait récupérer nos chiottes en ville
les [ __ ] parce que ce sont nos
emplois un nom de dieu la zae pente nous
voler notre travail suit des honnêtes
français un discours que l'on peut
entendre en savoie désormais un preuve
de sa bonne intégration dans la
magnifique république française alors
l'exode il a changé au cours des années
toujours une région puis l'autre sans
toutefois s'arrêter après la seconde
guerre mondiale c'est surtout l'ouest
qui en fait les frais ou encore
l'intérieur de la corse qui perd 90 % de
sa population entre 1960 et 1990 c'est
beaucoup
il existe même des régions pour
lesquelles l'exode rural fut au début un
avantage comme la lorraine et le nord de
la france qui ont bénéficié de
l'industrialisation dotées de bassins
miniers l'exploitation du charbon de
l'acier et leur exploitation dans
l'industrie lourde ont permis d'avoir
une croissance démographique positive
même si leurs campagnes se sont aussi
vides et les départs étaient largement
compensés par les arrivées
sauf qu'aujourd'hui si région autrefois
porteuse une activité économique
nécessaire et même stratégique se
prennent dans la gueule la
désindustrialisation
désormais c'est les nordistes et les
lorrains qui fut leur région à qui on
associe les clichés
autrefois réservé aux savoyards aux
bretons aux auvergnats depuis quelques
temps d'ailleurs sa voix et bretagne
sont devenus les terres d'accueil
département de haute-savoie est même
désormais le département français le
plus dynamiques démographiquement
parlant il compte maintenant plus de
huit cent mille habitants
c'est trois fois plus qu'en 1946 qu'il
est et le nord ce vide désormais le sud
de la france et la façade atlantique
refont plein bref ce qui a trak tiff
aujourd'hui était peut-être l'une des
régions que l'on fuyaient hier et vice
versa cette inversion de paradigme elle
est très présente en belgique d'ailleurs
la wallonie autrefois syrie je prenais
la flotte paysanne de haut et ce sont
désormais les premiers qui passent pour
des pouilleux et les seconds pour des
bourgeois par ailleurs impacts
spécifiques à ce pays l'exode rural
wallon contribuera à la francisation de
bruxelles qui était une ville de langue
flamande il ya encore un siècle
tu vois par exemple vient de l'est
on passe pour des arriérés maintenant
alors oui je suis parti j'ai pas eu le
choix
et du coup je suis venu m'installer ici
ce que c'est que les matches sont plus
sympa quoi un peu la situation je suis
en train de vivre en ce moment c'est à
dire bah je suis sûr que bientôt je vais
pas voir choix non plus et je vais aller
faire un tour dans la maison d'en face
parce que ça a l'air quand même pas
choquant que le cool que tentant de te
plaindre
et d'ailleurs je vais aller bonne chance
avec les lieux
[Musique]
mais du coup assistons à une
revitalisation des campagnes en fait oui
mais non tout d'abord les campagnes
restent relativement peu attractive si
vous vouliez une école un accès à une
gare un service de transport en commun
ou encore un hôpital où vous soigner il
existe chaque année de moins en moins de
communes disposez vous fournir ses
services
et oui la raréfaction des services
publics se poursuit encore effet fait de
répulsifs sur les actifs qui sont ceux
qui soutiennent souvent le gros de
l'activité économique d'une région que
ce soit par la force de travail ou par
les recettes fiscales
quitte à s'installer quelque part alors
autant éviter que ce soit pour voir la
fermeture de la maternité un
regroupement scolaire conduisant à un
déplacement de l'école ou encore le
démantèlement de la dernière ligne de
chemin de fer
du coup les jeunes continuent de se
tirer des blade et ceux qui s'installent
ne sont pas forcément ceux qui peuvent
régler le problème structurel de la
baisse démographique
ils n'ont pas le même âge ni les mêmes
besoins impact sur la natalité n'est
souvent pas perceptible en france il
existe un phénomène des lieux tropisme
c'est-à-dire de migration des personnes
âgées vers les territoires ensoleillée
pour y passer une belle retraite
un phénomène qui attire des vieux
d'ailleurs au passage comme les anglais
qui viennent vivre pépère en dordogne
or la priorité des vieux c'est pas
d'avoir une école dans le village c'est
plutôt d'avoir à un d-pad par exemple si
on en trouve relativement peu à paris
les départements ruraux en sont bien
dotés en france les ehpad privés sont
sans surprise surtout répartis le long
de la côte d'azur
si l'arrivée du numérique et du
télétravail aurait pu représenter une
aubaine pour redynamiser les campagnes a
eu l'effet inverse
à l'heure où les habitants des villes
parlent de la fibre ceux qui peuplent
nos villages non encore parfois pas
l'adsl 2,4 millions de foyers français
n'ont même pas un demi méga secondes de
connexion c'est à dire presque rien
finalement et six cent mille vivent
carrément zones blanches en 2017 90 %
des parisiens avaient accès au très haut
débit contre 1 % des habitants de la
crise ou de la dordogne
[Musique]
sont vraiment sans gêne ce citadin de
ces morts battant mais c'est arnaud
arnaud
stupide et quand c'est bien dit de voix
va être fun cette semaine
franchement mais pourquoi ceux qui
restent il décide d'y rester dans ces
conditions pour partir ou pas rester
benoît coquard sociologue a justement
écrit un ouvrage appelé ceux qui restent
qui se confondent souvent avec ceux qui
disent c'était mieux avant pour beaucoup
c'est parce qu'ils n'ont pas pu partir
tout simplement par manque de réussite
scolaire par manque de relation par
manque de moyens mais aussi parce que
l'ancrage familial ou territoriale était
trop fort pour perpétuer l'histoire
familiale
ce qui reste c'est aussi ce qu'ils
voient les autres partir et qui vivent
un déclassement social qui tranche avec
les générations précédentes
leurs parents aux grands parents durant
les trente glorieuses avait des
perspectives d'avenir et des emplois
stables mais ça c'était le bon temps
chez les jeunes qui restent c'est le
coup dur quand on peut pas se déplacer
quand il n'ya pas de cinéma de loisirs
que toute activité s'inscrit dans un
environnement social limité et donc que
tout le monde connaît tout le monde pas
l'ennui est souvent mis présent et par
ennui les adolescents casse des panneaux
et crame des poubelles
c'est aussi con que ça ils boivent aussi
à la campagne emploi plus et on boit
plus jeunes parents nuit souvent là
aussi c'est l'un des rares moyens
sociabilisation il ya deux fois plus de
jeunes de 17 ans à boire régulièrement
de l'alcool à la campagne qu'en région
parisienne et moins de personnes c'est
moins deux candidats possibles à la
reproduction
c'est très creux dit comme ça mais c'est
la vérité la sexualité celle des jeunes
filles notamment est un enjeu de lutte
très très tôt au collège la séparation
entre les filles qui couchent et les
autres est très forte
et dans cette lutte si l'on trouve des
garçons du même âge on en trouve
également des plus vieux et tout se sait
une bagnole garer à tel endroit ou un
scooter qui passe interurbain c'est
certain ces machins qui couche avec
quelqu'un
les rencontres se font via un réseau
limité de personnes et vos parents
savent qu'ils vous fréquentez avant que
vous ayez la chance de leur en parler
les étiquettes sont vite collé les
réputations sont vite forgé et elle
colle à la peau même des années plus
tard une fois bien installé avec la
petite famille de manière générale à la
campagne on couche plus tôt la part des
moins de 15 ans ayant eu un rapport
sexuel y est plus forte cette pression
dépucelage touche avant tout les garçons
qui sont plus nombreux à coucher plus
jeunes cela crée d'autant plus de
déception rétrospectivement il aurait
aimé coucher plus tard
quant au jeune fille de cet âge qui
souvent fréquente des hommes plus vieux
elles disent fréquemment qu'elle n'avait
pas vraiment envie de relations
sexuelles
il faut dire que dans un monde où
l'hétérosexualité n'est jamais remise en
question et suspects de ne pas avoir été
en couple passé 16 ou 17 ans le célibat
est une preuve d'un manque de valeur sur
le marché conjugales
l'injonction pour se mettre en couple
est donc très forte cette pression à
mesure que les couples se forment autour
de nous est d'autant plus forte les
études terminées puis dans la
actif dans un territoire à faible
population quand on est dans ce qui
reste il ne faut surtout pas finir dans
les derniers célibataire c'est
localement identifié comme un problème
et pour le résoudre il faut faire avec
les meufs où les mecs qui reste quoi
bref à la campagne le couple s'installe
et cohabitent plus rapidement beaucoup
doivent un an vivre chez les parents de
l'un des partenaires ce qui renforce
l'exclusivité sexuelle et l'engagement
conjugales
pour beaucoup de jeunes femmes le couple
permet l'indépendance vis-à-vis de sa
propre famille l'accès à de nouveaux
lieu de sociabilisation une forme de
reconnaissance sociale localement plus
fortement confrontés au chômage et la
précarité les femmes cherchent surtout
les hommes plus âgés et déjà insérés sur
le marché du travail et ceux dédiés
alors souvent un projet maternelle en
revanche un homme rural sans expérience
professionnelle a peu de chance de
connaître la vie de couple par ailleurs
les femmes rurales sont aussi moins
disposé à quitter leurs partenaires de
par les impacts socio économiques qui
sont souvent préjudiciable de fait elles
sont plus souvent exposés aux violences
conjugales et un truc super intéressant
dans le film des filles du docteur march
ou le personnage dès midi que le mariage
c'est une question économique mais ça
c'est un truc qu'on voit quand gary
becker ont commencé à parler du mariage
il en a parlé comme d'un marché c'était
dans les années 70 quelque chose comme
ça et quand tu reviens dans les époques
que ce soit avec la dot ou la doit à
chaque fois tu vois que gars quand il ya
un mariage kantienne mise en couple il
ya de la tune qui ait changé ça va dans
tous les sens ça peut aller de la
famille de la mariée vers la famille des
mariés de la famille des mariés vers les
autres marié vers les nouveaux mariés ça
va vraiment dans tous les sens mais à
chaque fois il ya de la tune qui ait
changé et ça montre bien un truc c'est
que le mariage c'est un truc économique
pourtant avant ça les économistes ont
mis vraiment du temps à s'y intéresser
alors que ça touche à plein de sujets
intéressants que ce soit la démographie
la location du temps libre même les
inégalités de revenus et de patrimoine
non mais s'attendre à ce que je dis tout
à l'heure j'ai suggéré qu'il y aurait
une revitalisation des campagnes et
c'est vrai en partie à condition de ne
pas être loin d'une ville accessible par
le train ou le tout est de ne pas être
trop tatillon sur le sens du mot
revitalisation aussi parce
qu'aujourd'hui vivre en ville ça coûte
cher
super cher même à paris se loger coûte
en moyenne 1065 euros par mois alors que
le smic net perçu en france et 2002 119
euros
comme les bailleurs demande au moins 3
fois votre loyer en salaires le calcul
est vite fait impossible de combiner
salaire minimum et centre-ville pourtant
que ce soit à paris ou une autre la
ville a besoin de ces éboueurs de ces
femmes de ménage de ces caissières de
ces travailleurs sociaux de ces
guichetier de ces vendeurs bref et
centres urbains ont besoin de personnel
qui ne peut pas se permettre de vivre
sur place
il lui faut alors vivre autour c'est la
périurbanisation ainsi chaque métropole
en france est associé un territoire qui
fait office de réservoir et de dortoirs
le foncier y est moins chère les impôts
locaux également et chacun peut y avoir
sa petite maison individuelle avec son
jardinet désormais ça alors là que
l'essentiel de la croissance
démographique française et concentré si
les gens fuient la ville alors c'est
pour s'installer dans sa bordure sans
pour autant cesser d'y travailler
il se forme autour des centre-villes des
couches en oignon la première couronne
succès de la deuxième puis la troisième
puis la quatrième couronne le cercle
grandi et le bord est toujours plus loin
du centre qui reste néanmoins le point
de convergence
aujourd'hui l'espace périurbain recouvre
38 % du territoire français
métropolitain pour même pas un quart de
la population française qui habite
nous sommes donc les champions d'europe
de l'étalement urbain est loin devant
les autres genres loin la
périurbanisation est problématique sur
le plan social parce qu'elle chante rifi
les territoires absorbé par
l'agglomération urbaine les habitants
plus favorisés s'y installent provoquant
une augmentation du coût de la vie
localement et donc une fuite des
premiers habitants qui ne peuvent plus
se permettre de rester
les ouvriers en premier la
gentrification peut aussi conduire à la
mort des petits commerces indépendants
qui pâtissent de l'augmentation de la
valeur immobilière par une augmentation
des loyers sans pour autant bénéficier
de la richesse et nouveaux arrivants qui
préfèrent d'autres commerces plus
branchée elle s'accompagne aussi de
l'effet nimby not in my backyard c'est à
dire bah pas dans mon arrière-cour le
nain liste car c'est le nom qu'on lui
donne va se poser à certaines politiques
locales ou encore à l'implantation de
certaines infrastructures pour ne pas en
subir ce qu'il perçoit comme un effet
négatif tout en profitant de leur
existence
c'est ainsi que les nuisances sont
déplacés dans les régions les moins
favorisés que les hommes
ce tri polluantes sont implantées dans
les régions les plus pauvres et que les
aéroports qui desservent les villes où
les éoliennes qui les alimentent se
retrouve en réalité à proximité deux
petits villages qui souvent ne l'ont pas
voulu et qui n'en bénéficie pas
directement ou encore que les
populations défavorisées sont poussés à
partir là où elles ne toucheront plus le
paysage
[Musique]
l'impact est aussi environnemental les
villes et installer au coeur des régions
fertiles l'agrandissement de leur
banlieue et l'artificialisation des sols
d'heure périphérie réduit les terres
agricoles disponibles comme les
périurbains un travail en ville alors
qu'ils sont forcés de vivre de plus en
plus loin de ce lieu de travail les
déplacements quotidiens banlieue ville
augmente alors du coup tu as des effets
sur l'environnement des impacts sur
l'environnement de la périurbanisation
le premier qui me vient à l'esprit qui
est peut-être le plus évident c'est
l'artificialisation des milieux et la
fragmentation des habitats
quand tu construis des logements ou des
infrastructures pour les transports mais
forcément tempête sur des milieux plus
ou moins naturel qu'ils soient
terrestres ou aquatiques et dans ce cas
là bas soit sa ruine tout un écosystème
soit ils sont seulement perturbée ou
dégradés ça entraîne aussi des obstacles
à la libre circulation de la faune et de
la flore avec des barrières lumineuses
sonores ou physique
mais du coup ça je t'en parle est un
autre jour parce que j'ai vraiment
beaucoup de trucs à dire là dessus mais
du coup quand tu parles d'obstacles tu
parles par exemple d'une femme moi ce
qui me vire en tête ses rangs les bois
de chemin fer typiquement genre là les
voies de tgv ou vraiment à clôturer sur
les côtés parce que ben là où de vitesse
fait que le gibier ne peut pas passer au
genre de truc c'est ça et du coup tu
peux avoir des aménagements qui passe
par dessus ce qu'on appelle des échos
duc ou de sous pour les amphibiens
par exemple moi quand tu me quand il me
dit ça ça me fait penser à un truc
peut-être que j'ai peut-être que je me
trompe peut-être que j'aie mal lu mais
il semble avoir l'homme justement que le
rhône et la scène comme c'est
relativement bettoni zay comme comme
berges sadc a tendance à plus facilement
débordé ouais exactement c'est
l'imperméabilisation des sols du coup on
accélère la circulation des eaux et on
se retrouve avec des problèmes de
ruissellement et souvent d'inondations
et des sol bétonné c'est aussi des sols
qui stocke beaucoup moins de carbone et
comme tu l'expliqués aussi tout à
l'heure tu as des augmentations de
trajets domicile travail qui du coup
entraînent des émissions de co2 et du
coup bas la qualité de l'air s'en
retrouve aussi impactés suite ajoute à
ça d'éventuels problèmes de pollution
via des déchets pollution des eaux
pollution paysagère avec le mitage et
bah ouais du coup la périurbanisation
touche pas mal la biodiversité et quant
à des projets comme ça d'aménagement qui
peuvent dégrader la biodiversité
tu peux aussi avoir des mesures
compensatoires mais souvent les dégâts
occasionnés sont irréversibles et ont
fait que qu'aggraver l'état de
conservation de certaines espèces qui
sont déjà un très bon état pour les
espèces bon du coup si vous croisez des
mariés un peu fliqué au bled ce sont
certainement des citadins qui viennent
profiter du cadre bucolique et peut-être
même qui viendront s'installer la
campagne rachetant un petit pavillon qui
autrefois partenaire un ouvrier qui n'a
plus les moyens et ce sera plus vraiment
à la campagne mais plutôt une cité
dortoir au service de la métropole dont
les bords se rapproche de plus en plus
penser à ces clichés mais c'est pas faux
pour autant si on pourrait croire que
l'exode rural est aujourd'hui terminée
sait seulement qu'il cage nouvelle
réalité qui ne résolvent pas le problème
de la fracture territoriale
ceux qui partent et ceux qui arrivent
n'ont pas les mêmes profils
sociologiques les mêmes intérêts donc
par exemple que les vieux viennent
passer une retraite campagnard de sa
cour pense peut-être les départs mais
comme ils ne font plus de gamin et que
ceux qui en font pour une montée en
ville pas ça résout aucun problème de
fond
eh oui si la convergence des modes de
vie entre la campagne et la ville merci
internet notamment
il demeure toujours un fossé des
inégalités ce n'est pas parti pour
s'arranger parce que oui avoir une
maternité une gare ou une école à
certains endroits ça devient un luxe est
un enjeu de lutte et bien merci d'avoir
regardé cette vidéo est bien évidemment
abonnez vous abonnez vous mettez des
commentaires et des laïcs et
rejoignez-nous sur le discorde vous
pourrez trouver plein de gens sympas
mais qui parlait et actuellement je suis
en direct sur twitter pour parler de ce
sujet précis on va parler d'eux
peut-être ma jeunesse à la campagne ça
va être sympa
[Musique]
alors ça avance avec les légumes comme
tu vois ça avance à son rythme est il
m'avait pas dit que si tu étais ancien
coloc du vortex j'avais la saison
d'avant du môle et ses personnels en
fait non mais ça ça change rien à ses
fins a des bons joueurs
moi je vois surtout qu'elles m'ont
offert le café qu'on a bien discuté et
qu'elles sont pas rancunière et
rancunière de quoi non rien mais teinté
de reggae et hésitant avec elle parce
que j'ai pas envie de passer des
vacances dans une sale ambiance c'est
l'ambiance et les couples
[Musique]